Most of us can think back to a key role a
teacher played in shaping our world view or career.
In my case, one such person was Dr. Hiram Curry,
a general practitioner who retrained in Neurology and then founded
the first academic family medicine department
where I worked in one of the first ambulatory E.H.R. systems.
He taught me many things but one in particular is relevant to this topic.
He used to caution his residents that they would see patients for a few minutes
every so often and think that what they did
in those brief encounters would make all the difference.
He was fond of saying that what the patients did
between those encounters would actually make that difference.
You know that chronic disease accounts for most health care costs.
You also know that a root cause is often behavioral with poor diet and
lack of sufficient physical activity being key health determinants.
You also know that once patients get chronic disease,
their compliance with the prescribed treatments is a key driver of the outcome.
In the past, patients were often asked to maintain logs of diet,
activities or treatment compliance.
Today of course, inhealth technologies such as smartphone apps and the plethora of
wearable devices provide an entirely new approach
to the maintenance of health and the management of disease.
This domain of Health Informatics,
now often called mHealth,
seeks to use data from mobile apps,
standalone or wearable devices and other sensors to understand health and health stays
to inform health care actions and to change our behavior
in order to prevent disease onset.
It also uses the data to promote behavior change once disease develops such as
medication inherence and increasingly to
provide clinical treatment such as virtual physician visits,
disease management or cognitive behavioral therapy.